さぁ ！皆さん
やって参りました！
ゴールデンウィーク
さっ！皆さん何をしてますでしょうか？
部活とかある人もいればぁ
お仕事の人もいるかもしれない！
凄い暇な人もいるかもしれない
とーっても遊びに行く人もいるかもしれない
まぁ、僕はですねぇ
遊ぶ人がいません。
(真顔)
ボッチキャラとかそういうのじゃなくて
リアルに…遊ぶ人がいませんでした。
後輩は実家に帰るし
僕と同じ代の人は皆
もう卒業して働いてて
なんか、他の場所に行ってるし
実家の富山にも帰ってないし
あの～
リアルボッチです！
ガチな方でちょっと遊ぶ人がいないんですけども
まっ、せっかくこういうちょっと
ゆっくり出来るんすよ今日は！
という訳で今日の動画はですねー
はじめの
のんびりゴールデンウィークの1日～！！
(ぱちぱち)
ボトゥっ
(とんとん)
これ、ポテチな。
今日は一人でのんびり
ゆる～くちょっと適当に
バイクで行ってみようと思いま～す
バイバ～イ
～♪
(カチッ)
(エンジンのかかる音)
～♪
(ぴろろん)
あの～
ついたのはいいんですけどぉ
流石ゴールデンウィーク
人が多くて恥ずかしいでござる
え、めっちゃ人いるんだけど
変な目で見られても
こう、なんか
なんとかなる気がしてるんですよ！
こう、自分に自信を持って行きます！
うん！
俺変なことしてないからね
自分を撮って
自分の動画を出すっていうのは
僕ですから
もぉ…
あれです
周りは気にしずに行きましょう
てかこの大量の松の木があるにもかかわらず
海が近くにあるっていうのが
三保の松原でございます。
(白目)デンッ♪
どこも松の木だらけになってます
はい
(ドドン♪)
ほらっ！
ほらほら！ちょっと
もうちょっとね、海が近いんですよ
(ドドン♪)
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
多分俺は
「羽衣の松」っていう所に行きたいんだから
こっちだな
多分行きたい所はね
多分海沿いからでも行けるんで
ただ海沿いに行くと、人が沢山いるから
ちょっと恥ずかしいんですよね
まぁそこはもぉ
心を鬼にして行くしかないということで
おぉ～
(波の音)
砂
なーんでね、人が俺を見るかわかったよ
僕あれです
自撮棒を使ってるんじゃなくて
三脚を手に持っているからー
ゴツイんですよね
完全に
よし、おまえらだいぶ来たぞ
(鼻水：ずずっ)
もぉね、ちょっとメンタルが落ち着いてきたから
誰が見ててもたぶんね
もう、自撮りまったく出来る感じまで
もぅ　きてる
で、こっちがもう全部
松の木で
こっちはもう
海みたいな
これがっ！
三保の松原 の
見どころです！
やっぱ、ゴールデンウィークは
結局カップルが多いんだよなっ
花粉かな…
(鼻をかむ音)
こっち側はね、多分人が少ないから
あっち側に行きましょう
定期的に自撮りしに外に出た方がいいですね！
人目がね
いや、でもゴールデンウィークってのがやっぱデカかった
うっすら、富士山が見えます
実は皆さんのおかげで
チャンネル登録者の伸びが
多分、今日本で一番
凄いことになってるんですよ。
で、まぁそれに伴ってですね
ま、僕も結構…
プレッシャー…
まっプレッシャーまではいかないんですけども
やっぱ、いろんな人が見てくれるから
ちょっと頑張んなきゃなって思っちゃってね…
こぉなんか、ちょっと
面白い動画を撮らなきゃ、撮らなきゃと
思っちゃうことがあるんですけども
まぁ、それはちょっと違うなと、
思いまして
うん
まぁ、昔はこういう動画も出してたんで
あんまり
ムリに、面白い動画を撮らなきゃ撮らなきゃと
思うより
やっぱ、自分の撮りたい動画とかね
ゆる～く撮れる動画とかも必要だと思ってます
これからもちょっと、こういうゆるい動画を
大切にしていかなきゃぁ…
僕が、
ちょっとダメになりそうなんで
みなさん
これからも ゆる～くよろしくお願いしますって感じですよ！
大事だと思います
こういうゆるいのも
ムリしたらやっぱ楽しくなくなっちゃうからね
！？
！？！？！？
ボォォールゥ！！？？
待ってろっつ！！！
今助けるからなっつ！！
おっしゃ！
うぅはっっ…はっ…
あぁ…
はっっ…
はっ…
オラァァァ！！！！！！(ドンッ)
おまえら…信じれるか
これが俺のゴールデンウィークだ
やけど、まだ土曜日だから
まだこれから、始まったばっかりなんで
けど…なんかホントびっくりするくらい
遊ぶ人がいないｗｗ